Michael dem been ski is using satellite
images and wartime reconnaissance maps
to locate a train filled with gold
allegedly hidden by the Nazis in the
dying days of World War two
his search brings him to a vast
underground Nazi complex called Project
research reserve is the German word for
giant extending as far as six square
miles the abandoned complex is one of
the largest subterranean structures on
the planet
the scale of these construction projects
is absolutely unimaginable the Germans
build miles and miles of underground
complexes for hiding things
the complex has only been partly
excavated and explored a large part of
this labyrinth was sealed off after the
Nazis abandoned it in 1945 it took
23,000 slave laborers dragged from Nazi
concentration camps to dig this
extraordinary tunnel complex they were
almost all worked to death from
exhaustion and starvation it is known
that the Nazis used tunnels to house
secret armament projects like the
construction of the v2 but what these
tunnels were for remains a mystery
dan Minsky is looking for clues for
tunnels tall enough to accommodate a
train for signs of train tracks for
indications that tunnel entrances have
been blocked or sealed nearly a mile
into the hillside and Dan Vince key
encounters a problem the tunnels are
flooded
to go any further divinsky must continue
by boat
that is amazing
why on earth were the Germans building
this what was this all about the tunnels
here are big enough to hide a train but
it's hard to tell if there are remnants
of railway tracks beneath the water
dan Minsky needs to review the satellite
images there must be a spur
connecting the railway to this and the
question is where